All right, well.
Bye.
Whew.
Here's the craziest
thing about last night.
Like his body just--
It felt like home.
Dude, does this taste
skunked to you?
No.
What does he do?
Okay, we did
not get to that,
but according to Google,
like finance, maybe.
What'd you get into
last night?
Nothing.
Actually, I got kind
of hammered.
God, I like,
miss him.
I'm gonna text him.
Oh,
you should wait.
No, the amazing thing
is that we're not playing games.
Oh my God.
( phone alert )
No idea who
that is.
How hard is it to open
a joint checking account?
And this is for you
and your husband?
Husband?
I--
I guess, I guess.
I have a feeling.
Mm-hmm.
This is it.
This is my
wedding cake.
This place
is perfect.
Unless he's Jewish.
Whatever, it's my day,
right?
You know what?
There's one more thing
I'd like to take a look at.
You know what?
I just--
I feel it.
I feel like Matt and I will
just be at peace here.
Yeah.
God.
You know what?
I'm gonna call my boo-boo,
see what he's up to.
( phone ringing )
Hello?
Hey.
Just at the cemetery,
thinking boutcha.
What are you thinking
for tonight?
I'm literally
down for whatever.
Who is this?
Uh, it's Amy.
We--we hung out last night,
I came back to your place.
Right, yeah.
Sorry, I think
I'm gonna take a pass
on us seeing each
other again.
Did I wear a bag?
What a dick!
Ma'am, should
I stop digging?
Yeah.
Wait.
What's your name?
My name's Charles.
Amy Charles.
Keep digging.
♪
♪ Somebody's really
pretty today ♪
♪ Somebody's
really pretty today ♪
( phone text beeping )
( shutter clicking )
Ugh.
God.
( shutter clicking )
( shutter clicks )
Ooh, ooh.
( phone ringing )
Jess?
( Jess )
What's wrong?
Okay, Bobby just text me,
he wants me to send him, like,
a sexy picture.
Oh my God, did you?
No, no, I've been trying
and they're just,
like, really bad.
Should I just
send him that one where--
Remember I met Hillary Clinton
at LaGuardia?
Should I
send him that one?
You can, like, basically see
my nipple.
They made me take it off
Facebook,
so it's
definitely not not sexual.
You're taking them yourself?
Yeah... Wait, what?
Honey, let me call
my guy.
Your guy?
( phone text beeping )
Oh, that's Bobby again.
Okay, I'm calling Danny P.
right now.
Danny P.?
( knocking )
Hi, come on in.
Hi, thank you.
Cute place.
Do you teach art
to cats?
Can I
offer you something?
Offer me what?
Half a coconut water
and the dirt from your Brita?
I think I'm actually good,
lonelybones,
I'm kind of in a rush.
What do you got already,
let's see.
Ooh.
Why the cactus?
That's not a--
that's not a cactus.
Okay, we need the bush
team on standby,
it looks like
she's got a Hasidic rabbi
living in her underpants.
No offense.
Okay.
We're just gonna clean you up,
it'll take a second.
20 minutes.
Don't worry, you're in good
hands, okay?
I've done everyone's.
I'm talking Blake Lively,
Scarlett Jo,
George Lopez.
It was actually my idea to make
Brett Favre's dick,
like, bright yellow.
No, that was you?
That was me.
Let's get to it.
Did you
wear that yesterday?
Yes!
Very good, but don't forget
your duck mouth,
don't forget
that duck mouth.
Now you're in a boat.
You're in a boat because
you're Pocahontas
and it's the new world!
Maybe less feathers.
Smile like you don't
have Spanx on.
Yeah!
Lay back
and look really alluring.
Well, actually, don't
look dead.
You're pregnant!
You're pregnant with
gift cards !
Yeah!
Oh-- Are you
gonna ( bleep ) your pants?
Oh my God, are you gonna
( bleep ) your pants?
You're so comfy.
Too comfy.
Look, if you don't watch your
( bleep ) shadow,
I will remove it.
Here we go.
Yes!
You've got a secret and only the
pillow can know.
Wash yourself.
Wash your whole body and your
armpits and under your boobs.
Amy!
Oh no, there's a spider
in your hair!
There's a spider
No!
There's a spider in your hair,
get it out!
Yes!
We have our shot,
that's a wrap.
You were amazing.
Yoko!
Unplug everything, we're gonna
burn this rat's nest down.
You were so great.
I'd love to stay and chat, but
I've got to run downtown.
I have to shoot Diane Keaton
bottomless with a turtleneck
like an hour ago, I'm sure you
understand.
Oh my God, I just don't
know how to thank you.
Just get ( bleep ).
Bonsoir.
( phone sending tone )
( phone alert )
I was gonna get eyelash
extensions but
then I did get those Uggs
that I've been eyeing.
Oh, okay.
YOLO.
All right, yeah.
I guess so.
Um, hey, I'm gonna go get
another drink from the bar.
You want anything?
Ooh, yeah, would you get me
a Mexican Russian mojito bomb?
Babe, those take
forever to make.
Why don't you just get
a glass of wine or something?
No, please, babe!
Okay, oh, yeah.
Okay.
(kisses)
All right.
A skinny-girl one.
Okay.
Hey.
Hi, how you doing?
Nice party, huh?
Yeah.
Ooh, I like your shirt.
It's ironic.
Right.
Right?
That is ironic.
So how do you know Glen?
Oh, um, I don't know Glen.
He was my boyfriend's
roommate in college.
Okay, you don't have
to slip in that you have
a boyfriend, okay?
I was just making casual
conversation, all right?
You're just a four.
Wow.
I wasn't even making...
Sorry.
Excuse me.
No, no, no, no.
You're fine.
I haven't even had enough
drinks to be stumbling.
Which is a sign I should
probably get another one.
Yeah, I hear you.
(chuckles)
Can I get you something?
Oh, no, no, no.
My boyfriend's grabbing me one.
Wow, you're arrogant.
I was just trying
to be nice.
You don't have to cram in
that you have a boyfriend.
No, I wasn't doing that.
I only sleep
with Asian girls.
Pretty arrogant.
For a three.
I'm a four.
Looks like you don't know too
many people here either, huh?
Oh, no, I just...
(mouthing)
No.
(chuckles)
Where are you from?
Long Island.
Ooh, Long Island,
that's cool.
Yeah.
Can I get you a drink?
No, I-- I'm...
Yeah, that'd be great.
Yeah?
What do you want?
White wine.
Oh, I'll be right back.
Thank you.
Here.
Oh, wow.
That was easy.
(chuckles) Yeah.
This poor schmuck
over there is waiting
for this like
insanely complicated drink
that you have to like harvest
a field to make.
Oh, my God.
(laughing)
What kind of a piece of shit
wants a really refreshing
drink like that?
(both laughing)
So what town are you from?
I'm from Ronkonkoma.
You ever been to the Konk?
Oh, my God, you're amazing.
I'm so glad you were
at that party.
Mmm.
How do you know Glen?
I can't remember.
I'm having an orgasm
right now.
Oh!
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, go!
(laughs)
Oh, my God, yeah!
♪♪
Boyfriend,
I have a boyfriend.
Hey, Henry?!
And cup of cocoa
with an extra marshmallow
for my best girl.
What's up?
Merry Christmas.
(cups clank)
(slurping)
Okay, I feel like I have
to tell you something.
Remember the night
you met me at that party?
I was by myself.
I have, um--
Let me stop you
right there.
Because you will never be
by yourself again.
What?
What are you doing?
Will you marry me?
Oh, my God.
(violin playing)
Um...
Yep.
She said yep!
(laughing)
Yes!
I will.
Oh, you've made me
the happiest man in Ronkonkoma.
(monitor beeping)
Henry, I have to tell you
something.
I have a boyfriend.
Ever since we met,
that party,
he was getting me a drink
and it took too long.
God, I just didn't
want to be arrogant
and slip in that I had
a boyfriend.
I tried to tell you
after Bennett was born,
but by then, super weird.
Wow.
Slow your roll,
asshole.
I was never interested
in you anyway
'cause I'm gay, P.S.
What?!
I just needed a beard
so I could keep my job
at Halliburton.
Arrogant.
(flatlining beep)
(ringtone chiming)
Ooh!
(groans)
Oh!
There she is.
Baby, I missed you
so much.
Mwah.
Sorry things got
so out of hand at that party.
They were out of Malibu
so I got you some well rum.
Oh, I don't want this.
Oh, can I just have
a mudslide instead?
Please?
Well rum?
This is gonna be good.
Do we really
have to do this?
Yes, we're not
communicating.
We need help.
We're not
communicating?
Yeah, we're not
communicating.
I don't even know what
you're saying right now.
(door opens)
Hello.
Hi, I'm Chrissy Teigen.
I'm so sorry
about the wait.
Come on in.
Thank you so much
for seeing us.
No problem.
It's gonna
be fine.
So let's get started.
First of all, how long
have you two been together?
Four years.
Well, we had a good run,
if that's what you mean.
Well, I think it's great
you guys are both here.
It shows that
this relationship
is something that's important
to the both of you.
I'm sorry,
aren't you a model?
She's a supermodel.
You sound like a real
ass(bleep) right now.
I actually was a model,
but now I'm a clinical
social worker
and I really love it.
You know, I'm really
enjoying this now
and I mean, who wants
to ride a horse naked
for the camera
all the time?
I'd rather just
do that on my own.
And as you know, modeling
is great,
but you hit 27
and suddenly, you're old.
Oh, that's not old.
Amy's 37.
I'm 32.
Yeah, but you're
a drinker.
All right, so let's talk about
what brought you two here.
I'll start.
Um...
You know, when,
when Amy gets jealous,
I get really
frustrated.
So I have to like,
you know,
go to the gym and then
I gotta sweat it out.
Just... (growls)
And Amy?
Well, I, I feel like
he's cheating on me.
You just need to learn
to believe that I'm not.
Uh, well, these sound
like two very conflicting
perspectives, obviously--
Can you put your glasses
back on, please?
Of course.
Thank you.
No, no.
No, no, no.
No,
don't do that.
Okay, uh, well, he never has sex
with me, like at all.
It's because
I don't want to.
And Amy, how does
that make you feel?
That makes me feel unattractive,
Chrissy Teigen.
You know what, Kevin,
maintaining self-esteem
for a woman
can be really difficult.
I think we all feel
a little bit ugly sometimes.
All right, I want
to try a role play.
I'm going to be Amy.
Kevin, I'd like you
to say to me
all the things that you'd
like to do to Amy in bed.
Okay--
No.
I don't think that's
a good idea for us--
First, I want to kiss
you for hours.
And then I want
to run my fingers
through your long,
dark hair.
And then
I wanna drive you crazy
by licking you in places
no other man,
including John Legend,
has ever touched
before.
All right,
why don't you now
say those things
directly to Amy?
It's okay.
I think she got it.
I don't think
this is helping at all.
So it's agreed.
We're on a break.
You know what I like
to do sometimes is kind of
finish off the session
with just one of you.
I think that would be
the smartest deal here.
Okay, yeah.
Amy, you'll take
a Citi Bike home, right?
I've never even used
a Citi Bike.
It's really easy.
You just use a credit card.
Actually, Kevin, I think it's
best if I finish with Amy,
but, um, you know what?
My business cards
are still being made.
But all my information
is on this for you.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
We have a calendar--
Wow,
this has everything.
I will put this
to use.
Great, and then
I will see you Monday.
Monday.
Perfect.
I will see you then.
Monday.
See you at home.
See you.
Girl,
don't blow this, girl.
What?
That man out there
is a total catch.
You need to lock it down.
Really?
(phone chimes)
Oh, gross.
It's a dick.
It's Kevin.
(woman)
"My Dream Breakup."
Amy, a high
school graduate,
is ready to change her
relationship status
with her boyfriend,
Nick.
Hello, gorgeous.
Are you my
breakup girl?
Yes, hi.
Hi, come here.
Nick and I have been dating
for two-and-a-half years.
Nick is like, such
a great guy, but I just,
I know in my heart that I'm
ready for something taller.
So let's
talk general concept.
Have we given any thought to
whether you want it to be
a slow realization
or a devastating blindside?
Um, I guess
blindside feels more me.
You know what?
I knew you were going
to say that.
I just get you.
You do.
Let's look at
some venues, come on.
You know what?
I have an idea, Amy.
Let me tell you.
What do you
think about tapas?
I love the small
plates idea.
I think it's
a great fit for you, Amy.
You know, it's low commitment,
you can leave after
the bacon-wrapped figs
if you want, or if he's crying,
you can stay for
the croquettas!
Ooh, I love
croquettas!
Then we're gonna have
to make him cry.
You're such a natural.
Have you done
this before?
No. No.
Everyone always
breaks up with me.
Mom, one to 10?
♪♪
Mom.
When I divorced your father,
I wore something
more traditional.
This is my day!
Oh, sweetie.
No, you stop it.
You're ruining this!
(sighs)
Mom, can I talk to
you for a second?
(crying)
Why are you being mean?
That looks...
...great!
We have the dress!
(Amy)
I watched my friends
do this over and over again
and now it's my turn.
Blessed.
(whispers)
Hey.
Why are all
these cameras here?
Nick,
the times we shared can never
be taken away from us.
What are you
guys shooting?
But all things must run their
course and in due time,
even everything ends.
So Nick, today, I'd like
to tell you that
I am breaking up with you.
(mouthing words)
Go for
Eduardo and Pilar.
Wait, what?
♪♪
We have tears.
Go for croquettas!
(man sings in Spanish)
Why the (bleep)
is he singing?
No, I'm sorry, no.
These are from Spain.
(groaning)
Sweetie, I'm sorry,
no singing, okay?
Lo siento.
But if I want to hear you sing,
I will put a dollar
in your (bleep) sombrero.
This is not the
(bleep) "Voice".
Do I look like I'm in
a spinny chair?
Please just
follow instructions.
I have 200 of you.
I don't even know what
to say right now.
I'm like,
totally blindsided.
What is this?
Oh, you're giving me my
stuff back in a gift bag?
Hey, (bleep) you, Amy.
Holy God!
Sweetie, you
were amazing!
You did it, girl!
We did it.
It couldn't have
been more perfect.
It was truly the breakup of
my dreams and the best part--
now I have a new
gay best friend.
Oh, I'm not gay.
I'm gonna (bleep) her.
♪♪